I as a historian know, there is
very little we can say about the next
100 years, let alone 10,000 years, for sure.
On the other hand we can say a lot
about the last 10,000 years. And actually it's
quite stunning how much more we know
now than we did a hundred years ago because
of the information memory technologies
that we're inventing now to mine material
evidence for information that we never
would have thought possible. Including
DNA forensic analysis. So I want
to focus tonight on what we can learn
about the future by looking at the past.
So I want to say that if you're really
interested in the next 10,000 years
you have no better evidence to
look to than the past 10,000 years
and that's what I want to talk about tonight.
Now the story actually begins
a lot earlier than "the long now." It begins
in the long ago. This actually dates
from about 40,000 years ago, we think.
I'll talk a little bit more about it.
But I think that memory technologies
and in fact human species really took
a real pivotal turn. That moment sort of
in the Garden of Eden or at least it was a
Garden of Eden moment when we realized
that we're going to die. As far as we
know there is no other species
that understands that they are going to die.
Not just that their own partners
or something dies, their children dies...
But that we anticipate that we're going to
die. We know that. And I think that it
changes everything for the way humans
think about time. Now I want to talk
a little bit more about that but this is
early evidence from long ago, about
40,000 years ago, that human beings
from the very beginnings became obsessed
with cheating death, in fact. And i look at
this technology of paint on cave walls
as the earliest concrete evidence of
cheating death by in fact extrapolating
the contents of our mental life our
imagination of you know our sort of
spiritual life. And putting it in a safe
place. Actually we're outsourcing it to
durable physical objects. And you can see
it's very familiar. We don't know
what these people are telling us. But
we know that they're human. And we
know that because they actually signed their
own piece of art. I think of this as the
earliest kind of... it's a Paleolithic
selfie, in a way. You know what's so
interesting is that as a species we are
not the strongest. We are not the fastest.
And we are not even the brainiest. I hate
to say it. But we actually don't have the
biggest brains. And we certainly don't
live the longest. The one thing that we
have is this amazing thing that we have
collectively created which is our
collective memory. A kind of collective
brain which is the thing that we keep
alive over generations. Which makes us
able to accumulate knowledge over time.
And actually we are now at this juncture
on the planet when we are not only the
dominant species on the planet, but
through our collective memory and
collective brain we are dangerously
dominant over the planet. That's another
reason why I think this is a really
critical time for us. You know
the sense that we have the certainty that we
are separate from other people that we're
going to die and this collective memory
that we have, have endowed us with
a couple of unique qualities from other species.
We have a certain temporal depth
perception which is very deep. Very
deep into the future and very deep into the past.
And through this temporal depth perception
we actually can engage in mental time travel.
We can deduce what happened
in the past, and we can project
that into the future.
We can engage in conjectural thinking.
And through language in fact, we can engage
in what I think of as synchronized
mental time travel. No better example is
that crew that 18 or 20 years ago
started to put together the New Horizons
mission to Pluto. And that team
and people cycled in and out of that team
at the JPL. That team was engaged in mental
time travel synchronized for an astounding
period of time and how they ended up
actually hitting their target after that.
Especially after the appropriations
scares they received along the way
from our friends in Congress. It's really
a testimony to how collective action and
collective memory really is
a very powerful thing.